alors Béatrice moi je vois que vous
n'allez pas rester sur le plateau
est-ce que vous voyez une lettre
recommandée en fait c'est un passage
vous amener à autre chose je vous vois
retourner sur quelque chose on me montre
l'image quelque chose avec du cinéma ou
quelque chose comme ça donc pour moi il
y a juste un passage ici sur TPMP mais
il y a quelque chose de beaucoup plus
important qui va prendre place par la
suite sur le côté justement qui va
revenir sur l'image un film quelque
chose comme ça c'est vraiment ça qui me
marque c'est vraiment l'écran en fait
parce qu'on la verra plus de deux
minutes dans ce film américain
pour moi
il y a une belle proposition qui arrive
est-ce que par exemple quelque chose sur
Daniel concernant le la rencontre
hypothétique
[Rires]
alors Daniel je ne vois pas tout de
suite la rencontre
je vais vous dire quelque chose Daniel
je pense que vous avez peut-être
comprendre je pense qu'il y aura un
événement important qui est pour moi
relativement proche qui va vous libérer
de quelque chose
qui va vous libérer en fait par rapport
à quelque chose pour moi il y a une
personne aujourd'hui qui peut vous
empêcher d'aller vraiment vers la
relation il y a quelque chose qui va se
libérer et qui va vous permettre pour
moi d'aller vers une rencontre mais je
ne le sens pas encore tout de suite
voilà bon un peu de patience je vous dis
ce que je ressens je me permets
je vous fais un gros bisou
[Applaudissements]
sur Gilles mais un truc qui met la pêche
pas le tout mais c'est pas grave
on en avait on en avait déjà parlé
moi je reste sur ce que j'ai vu je vois
toujours un mariage et je vois toujours
l'étranger par rapport à ce mariage
est très très festif voilà il y a des
îles et quelque chose comme ça donc je
reste là dessus en tout cas ça ça voilà
c'est toujours là ça c'est très bien
très bien très bien
[Applaudissements]
et sur je pense qu'elle est-ce qu'il va
malheureusement ressenter
je vois pas trop j'en fasse
ok mais je crois que Delphine était
approchée pour le pour une série
sur laquelle tu as été ta prochaine
et alors et sur moi
[Rires]
il y a toujours le théâtre que je vois
j'en avais parlé voilà et comme j'avais
parlé et il y a un renouveau par rapport
aussi un nouveau projet d'émission que
je vois il y a quelque chose d'autre qui
va se mettre en place ok il y a une
année pour moi la 2024
et tout ça je peux lui demander si
ah ouais
c'est trop tard
alors moi je dis oui je suis une
personne qui arrive c'est un homme qui
serait un petit peu plus avec vous
je vois quelqu'un d'assez quelqu'un
plutôt brun quelqu'un qui a voilà une
allure dans cette personne non je ne
vois pas de barbe pourquoi en tout cas
je vois vraiment l'amour qui va arriver
c'est peut-être un peu tardif mais
quelqu'un qui arrive il y aura vraiment
quelque chose qui se construit très
fortement avec cet homme là
dites-moi
42 41 42 il y a vraiment quelque chose
de positionner mais vous rencontrez
avant mais vraiment quelque chose de
positionner dans la relation sont sur
les 42 ans merci c'est une personne qui
aura des liens avec étrangers aussi
parce que j'entends je vois quelqu'un
j'entends la voix quelque chose comme ça
quelqu'un qui parle beaucoup de la
langue